major milestone for the David Pakman
show YouTube channel we have reached
four hundred thousand subscribers on
YouTube that is a really really big deal
for us and already several hundred
subscribers beyond that so first and
foremost thank you I mean four hundred
thousand when we started the YouTube
channel I was looking back today at our
YouTube analytics from September of 2009
I don't remember if it was I think
September 2nd of 2009 was the day that
david pakman show YouTube channel opened
or uploaded its first video the first
month of the David Pakman show YouTube
channel we had seven hundred and seventy
seven views one month seven hundred and
seventy seven views we now gained in the
range of five to fifteen thousand
subscribers per month with somewhere
between seven and twelve million views
per month so YouTube has become a major
major platform for us and to celebrate
this this Friday we are going to be
having a huge major big league
membership special that's going to
relate to the number 400,000 I won't
give it away yet but the membership
special that we're gonna have on Friday
will relate to the number 400,000 and
you'll be able to go to our website
david pakman.com slash membership i will
be emailing everybody a coupon code that
you can use in celebration of the four
hundred thousand subscriber milestone
all you need to do to be notified is go
to david pakman.com you'll see and if
you're watching you see exactly where to
do this as designated by the red arrow
here there's a place where you can type
in your email address and get on our
mailing list if you do that you will get
an email this friday with a huge
discount and i'm hugely excited about
this and four hundred thousand is great
the next milestone is five hundred
thousand so big things happening there
also another milestone coming up on
patreon which is that we are approaching
two thousand individual contributors on
patreon at patreon.com slash david
pakman show just forty-nine away we were
at 1951 patrons 49 more
gets us to 2000 and big things planned
for when we get to that as well all
right so that email fourth coming on
Friday just sign up for our newsletter